shoes
my name is anatom mati I'm a professor
of finance and economics at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business and I teach
interdisciplinary courses and I'm Rob
Siegel a lecturer in management here at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business
I teach a variety of classes here at the
school and today anat and I are going to
talk about our course business and
government power and engagement in the
21st century world
assistant
[Music]
our first point is that markets can work
well without functioning governments and
legal systems we take a lot for granted
around here at Stanford GSB we think
corporations just exist we think that
there are transactions in their
contracts and there is competition in
markets all these things and we don't
stop to think what makes that happen how
is it the day all these things come
about and what do you do if somebody
breaks the promise that they make to you
doesn't pay you a right time or it
prevents you from doing something after
you finished working for them because of
some non-compete agreement where do you
go you need a system to ensure that all
these things are working
leaders in business and leaders in
governments must remember that what they
do can protect lives and livelihoods or
it can also harm and endanger we have
numerous examples where we love products
and markets work great and everybody's
doing their bit and it all works out
but in this class we also saw examples
where both Business Leaders and
government leaders fail people for
example we saw a corporation sold a
product that became clear was unsafe for
children and yet they don't inform
consumers about it and they leave the
product on the market for a while and
even when they recall it they don't take
very much action to remove it from the
market and the government doesn't
disclose that information very broadly
and doesn't Force the corporation to
recall more aggressively
third we found that leaders need to find
and challenge assumptions and Wishful
Thinking including their own for example
we thought that assumptions people would
make and how they would assume markets
work and where markets would fail were
not always clear and obvious when people
dug down beneath their assumptions some
we also found that the capabilities and
competencies that were assumed of
leaders in business and government were
not always matched up to what people
thought was the world versus what the
reality actually held
fourth we found that leaders need to be
aware of false choices and misleading
labels that prevent us from getting at
core issues and understanding what's
really being discussed for example words
like capitalism and socialism regulation
and laws what are costly and what are
helpful and needed even trying to
understand things like critical
infrastructure is it best served by
government or is it best served by the
private sector and how does it serve the
citizens of a particular country or area
or Nation this can get in the way of our
understanding what are the core issues
that we're trying to address and really
understand what are we trying to
accomplish as humans and as a society
assistant
our fifth point is that effective
governance harnesses power information
and incentives to create trustworthy
systems we talked in this class about
institutions institutions of government
institutions in the private sectors like
corporations and in these institutions
there are leaders that have power that
have information and they have
discretion or a way to act good
governance means that they are
trustworthy and that they are
accountable for what they do that is the
opposite of abusive power and Corruption
you might say so creating trustworthy
system means creating institutions that
have good governance and if we do that
then we can Thrive as a society
[Music]
and that and I bring very different
backgrounds experiences and training to
these important topics one thing that
was very true and not and I disagree on
everything no Rob you're wrong we don't
disagree on everything we're grown many
things actually okay eventually yes we
do end up agreeing on everything
laughs
[Music]